speaking of uncomfortably you either way
the hodgetwins have offered to actually
be sacrificial entry to get over their
fears they're not big fans of dogs from
what I understand no looks like to bite
me
I don't trust dog no I'm I just walked
in the yard and dog just big black child
came running out freaking hey hey you
boom at time with uh they gave you some
chocolate Santa Clauses forearm mister
scooter sale because doesn't middle
school we was in middle school the
basketball team they have no money so it
was you know they had raised money for
the raise money
why were you in someone's yard yeah
trying to sell em chocolate soda close
[Laughter]
hey I'm trying to raise money for my
basketball team got some chocolate Santa
Claus yeah
well when I got bit I was actually a
door-to-door vacuum cleaner salesman oh
man I used to sell Kirby's daughter go
that's the worst possible thing because
yeah all dogs hate vacuum cleaner
hover evil we brought him in to get
bathed they be like oh man we love him
but when we try to dry him he really
hates the blow-dryer I'm like yeah he's
got a thing about it it looks like a gun
he doesn't like God we didn't know we
were scared for a second once we shut it
off so yeah oh so now were you in the
front yard or backyard I was in the
front yard front yard yeah yeah yeah it
sounds like you're retro actively
changing the story a little bit I don't
know how many times I've been walking
home from the store and I'm just walking
down a road dog just comes back nowheres
don't chase me so yeah Dex I was like
all black black tongue black gum just
black fur black I don't know why - I was
right around this iron it was just the
meter gasps here's big fangs he had
describing black-on-black crime it's a
little caca doll
so the dog comes running out and D&S I'm
turning to get away there's the Sun
beware of dog I'm like what the hell was
that well you know we're all about
getting past our fears here at loud it
was crowded in all capacities and so
actually today for the first time you're
gonna be you're gonna be feeding hopper
which brings us to our next and final
segment and pleated oh wait Omo I know
the hodgetwins get over there
debilitating fear of dogs alright so
yeah you're gonna be feeding uh because
when we first you first came here I
didn't realize you didn't you weren't
fans of hopper you saw him and you're
like you gotta lock him out a dog's a
killer yes but you your exact words what
you thought he was very large dog yes
like his neck is like big enough to
swallow my often if you want if he's
were so inclined yeah okay but we've
talked about this before like I said you
don't have to do this but everyone here
knows hopper pretty pretty gal and
Gerald you know hopper fantastic dog
want a sick dog he's only killed three
people that we know none of them were
vacuum salesman oh so one was a hair
dryer salesman but he had it coming
so obviously you don't have to but we're
just gonna have you and follow my
instructions feed him some some cheese
cuz how loves cheese that's what that is
that is just give him some cheese I'll
instruct you and on a scale from one to
ten how nervous are you
my heart's rate is increasing really you
just rankle sweat rolling down my back
right now
getting tight I don't want look I don't
want to look like a little girl on your
show right and I really appreciate it
because if someone said I had to pet a
tarantula I wouldn't do it oh the
difference in another segment
no one could promise me the tarantula
wouldn't bite me so I promise you
hoppers not going to bite you I will
bring him out you just feeding the
cheese follow my instructions and you'll
be good to go he's gonna he's gonna love
you maybe maybe he'll become dog people
yeah by the way my Canadian producer
Johnny boy he had no idea this was a
cultural thing black guys with dogs well
you see it on TV white people sick and
dogs on black people
well black people Shepherd and a fire
hose outside of a diner it really is
rough okay all right but we're so just
grab the cheese and what you do is to
have the cheese right now each other to
be a cheese and when we're gonna bring
him in you're just gonna stay in a high
voice hey Harper come over here and
you're gonna give give him the cheese
you can either hold it like this or just
hold it in your palm and just say hey
gentle gentle and he's gonna go do it
like this you can do it like that with
hopper like I do
he's very well turn he's very well
trained so just high voice and hey
hopper Goren if he doesn't come over to
you then we'll just abandon the whole
experiment because that means or
something isn't like about you all right
Johnny boy let's bring in bring in the
hopper monster and let's there we go
come on where is he
hopper okay call him over so he has to
go to you guys say look they got cheese
calm cheese over there
give it to you give it to wit my head e
all right okay opera come on get out of
here all right this has been the
hodgetwins getting over their fears or
not subscribe watch one of these other
videos or hit the notification Bell well
you should hit that if you subscribe
anyways because subscriptions don't mean
anything on YouTube anymore now you have
to get notifications that it shows up in
your inbox so I don't know why you
subscribe in the first place but that's
we have to do also making money off
these videos anymore because YouTube
decided why they just said we're not
going to and when we said why they
didn't tell us why exactly imagine if
you showed up to your job do your work
and then they said hey by the way we're
not gonna pay you said why they said
piss off